[Musik]
hallo herz für karosserie bildet heute
gibt es einmal richtig leckeres rezept
also ich sag ja immer richtig lecker
aber das hier heute ist wirklich super
lecker ich mache heute ein zitronen
hinziehen und zwar gibt es die drohnen
hähnchenschenkel aus dem ofen
hier habe ich schon mal vorbereitet und
es ist wirklich ein super einfaches
rezept ihr könnt das super vorbereiten
im kühlschrank marinieren und dann
einfach kurz vorher in den backofen
schieben
das heißt wenn ihr zum beispiel abends
spät von der arbeit kommt und keine lust
gehabt zu kochen dann bereitet morgens
alles vor oder auch am abend zuvor
stellt in den kühlschrank und am
nächsten abend einfach in den backofen
das ist wirklich super lecker vor allem
finde ich es nicht so schwer
die zitrone macht es wirklich super
fruchtig und frisch und ich werde sagen
ich rede gar nicht so viel sondern ich
zeige euch gleich die zutaten die
ständig hier vorne für das zitronen hund
brauche ich sechs hähnchenschenkel etwas
pfeffer
ich habe ich sechs zitronen plus eine
zitrone dich später in scheiben
schneiden
eine knoblauch knolle 1 stimme oregano
etwas rosmarin 120 milliliter olivenöl
fünf bis sechs rote zwiebeln drei
teelöffel salz zwei teelöffel
paprikapulver und noch ein kilo
kartoffeln
so erstelle ich jetzt einmal die
marinade her
und dafür brauche ich es ganz ganz viele
patronen und wie gesagt was ich jetzt
eine zitrone übrig die werde ich nämlich
später in scheiben schneiden und mit vom
hähnchen in den ofen dazu geben wie
zitronen nehme ich jetzt und massiert
die so ein bisschen die solltet ihr auch
bei zimmertemperatur lagern und nicht im
kühlschrank so schmecken sie besser und
der saft letztlich auch viel einfacher
auspressen so ein bisschen drücken und
dann den kompletten saft ausdrücken
[Musik]
vorletzte zitrone die schalen solle auf
jeden fall nicht wegschmeißen die könnt
ihr nämlich super als spielmaschine
nehmen das ist immer ein super tipp vor
allem richtig spülmaschine toll und
aufregend kalten und so weiter strikt
mich immer super jetzt habe ich hier den
zitronensaft und da kommen jetzt alles
und pfeffer rein pfeffer wird sich auch
ordentlich mit rein denn das findet der
marinade sowohl bis hinsehen als auch
für die kartoffeln reichen dann noch
olivenöl und das sieht jetzt noch
ziemlich viel auf aber glaubt mir das
braucht ihr auf jeden fall und später
wird es so lecker dass sie den sud auf
keinen fall später wegschmelzen möchtet
und euer brot renten werden versprechen
jetzt alles mit dem schneebesen
verrühren
ich werde später des zitronen hohen auf
einem blech zu bereiten jetzt nämlich
allerdings eine schale zum marinieren
ihr könnt aber auch direkt auf dem blech
marinieren aber so bekomme ich so ein
bisschen leichter in den kühlschrank
ich habe ich jetzt die schale nämlich
die hähnchenteile die kommen jetzt hier
rein
[Musik]
jetzt einfach schön einmassieren jetzt
kann ich sehr schön abdecken und dann in
den kühlschrank stellen für etwa vier
bis fünf stunden
ihr könnt das ganze auch gerne über
nacht marinieren und die restlichen
zutaten stelle ich jetzt kurz beiseite
und dann sehen wir uns nach der marinade
zeit das hähnchen ist jetzt mariniert
jetzt kann ich alles auf ein backblech
geben und ich nehme jetzt auch ein
tiefes backblech denn es ist sehr sehr
viel und vor allem tropft so einfach
nichts runter
ich habe die kartoffeln die sind bereits
gewaschen die gebe ich jetzt hier rein
und die ganz großen kartoffeln die
werden einfach halbieren ihr könnt ja
auch vierteln die zwiebeln nehme ich
jetzt und werde sie auch viertel
[Musik]
und hier habe ich jetzt noch die
knoblauchknollen da fehlt jetzt leider
eine knoblauchzehe arbeit ist es nicht
schlimm die nehme ich jetzt nicht
schälen sie gar nicht sondern schneidet
sie so durch lege sie jetzt auf wti
fällt jetzt auseinander hier oben das
macht aber nichts
wo legt jetzt mit der schnittfläche nach
unten einfach hier noch mit rein
die haut hier aus nämlich zweck die
stört später bestimmt aber wenn ihr die
ganze knolle habt dann fällt es auch
nicht so auseinander
nur hatte ich keine mehr die kräuter
kommen jetzt auch mit rein die könnt ihr
im prinzip auch schon mit seiner gnade
geben denn sie verbrennen im ofen
ziemlich schnell das habe ich jetzt
freundin vergessen also am besten mit so
marinade ich werde jetzt einfach mittel
früher aus dem ofen rausholen so die
katholisch einfach zu groß und jetzt
mache ich mal platz
ich sehe das ganze hier her macht so ein
bisschen platz wird das hähnchen
[Musik]
jetzt über die sich das ganze noch mal
mit der übrigen marinade das heißt die
marinade jetzt hier noch übrig war und
auch deutlich hier noch habe schön auch
die kartoffeln bedecken und jetzt nehme
ich einfach noch die übrig gebliebene
zitrone da ist jetzt auch ganz wichtig
dass sie unbehandelt ist also nicht
gespritzt hatte ich schneide ich jetzt
im scheiben und legt die auch noch
trocken das sieht jetzt zwar auf
brennelemente ist aber ne zitrone die
chance erhöhen aber das macht nichts
und so kann das gericht jetzt schon in
den ofen und zwar habe ich den schon
vorgeheizt auf 200 grad ober unterhitze
da kommt das gesamte hähnchen mit dem
tollen gemüse rein für etwa 40 bis 60
minuten eher etwas länger
und sobald die zitronen etwas zu dunkel
werden nehme ich sie auf jeden fall raus
und beim hähnchen ist es so ich zeige
euch das noch weiter her da schien und
nämlich so eine szene die sieht man
nicht aber man spürt sie und später
springt es hier weg und dann weiß ich ok
jetzt ist das hähnchen gar
[Musik]
jetzt gucken wir mal rein ins hähnchen
jetzt sieht man hier ganz deutlich dass
es hinten schon durch ist und zwar hat
sich hier diese szene gelöst das heißt
ich übergebe das hähnchen nochmal mit
dem sud und damit jetzt noch ein
bisschen farbe bekommen schiebe ich
jetzt ganz nach oben stellt den grill an
auf höchste stufe und dann lass es noch
einmal etwa fünf minuten bis die
gewünschte bräunung hat
[Musik]
[Applaus]
jetzt ist das hähnchen fertig es hat
noch mal richtig schön farbe bekommen
jetzt kann ich servieren das ganze haus
duftet ich weiß nicht genau ob es noch
zitronen hähnchen nach zitronenkuchen
duftet es riecht einfach richtig lecker
zitronig und jetzt anrichten aus der
kartoffel näher zitronenscheibe zur deko
und was ganz ganz ganz wichtig ist ist
dieser sog da müsst ihr nämlich gleich
das beeindrucken das ist wirklich super
lecker
im prinzip habe ich das handy nur
zubereitet wegen dem sie denn das letzte
mal habe ich einfach nur den tod
gegessen war echt voll lecker und dann
stelle ich das jetzt hier ab wer möchte
noch ein bisschen mehr salz drüber aber
ich muss natürlich erst vor abschmecken
und dann nehmt ihr euch eine scheibe
brot und stammt und ihr sieht es damals
in den sog nicht verbrennen
wie lecker das schon noch sehen
superlecker vor allem zitrone
die schmeckt man richtig gut raus was
ich auch wirklich ein ganz tolles sommer
auch im herbst gericht frühe winter egal
wann passt immer zu jeder jahreszeit und
hier seht ihr übrigens die
knoblauchzehen wurde die
knoblauchknollen die könnt ihr auch mit
anrichten
einfach so ein bisschen raus drücken und
das kann man auch super essen schmeckt
richtig lecker und das essen wir jetzt
hier wären nämlich alle richtig hunger
hunger richtig hunger deswegen könnt ihr
das rezept nachlesen auf sell off -
blog.de wir werden jetzt gemeinsam essen
und lassen es uns wirklich gut schmecken
den sud wirklich auf jeden fall alles
aufheben alles ins also brot tunken so
viel es geht und ich wünsche euch ganz
viel spaß danach machen und bis zum
nächsten mal
[Musik]